people try to place you in a box when
you're a black writer
as if other audiences can't enjoy your
material it's like we just put our head
down and written 44 books over the span
of 11 years we looked up and we're the
youngest african-american authors
as a couple to make the new york times
it changed our life
we from flint in particular i'm from the
fifth world of flint it's one of the
roughest neighborhoods it's doggy dog
but i love it because it taught me how
to come from the bottom
our city is dark but once you figure out
how to utilize that darkness that's when
you become great
we're writing about
the things
that america covers up the neighborhoods
that you don't see
and that you never hear about our books
are us
it's black america in the next show
[Music]
well when we met each other our mutual
passion was writing i was 15 years old i
fell in love and you know she ended up
becoming my wife
we just wrote we barely slept we barely
ate we definitely didn't leave the house
there was no formula for it
now we use systems we have a system
where we write every single thought on
post-its and we stick them anywhere
around the house
we feel like our words are worth dollars
so anytime you forget something you're
it's like flushing money down the toilet
so we don't want to ever let a thought
pass us by
i love when i walk into
a bookstore and i see
the cartel sitting next to a james
patterson book because that's where it
belongs i remember in the beginning i
would go in the bookstore and move the
books to the front
it's important to erase that street
fiction moniker when you label something
street fiction you immediately put it in
a small section in the bookstore and
only
certain people will go to that section
we're very fortunate to have broken out
of that box and we hope that now that
we've opened the door
that other black riders can come through
that door behind us
[Music]
we don't want to be great for this
lifetime we want to be great for five
generations down
back then we was chasing the checks now
we're chasing history
[Music]
[Music]
you